dad's obsessed with the octopus and
everything's got to be done his way now
they told me how to make this story time
okay first things first
Trey into the other fairy
why aren't you gonna get to do anything
on my watch no no I need to watch cook
with your eyes pinch of salt in that
please okay study at the middle yeah
right hey no show please watch the one
that's really good at cracking eggs you
see like you try to be fancy lip
there's no shirt in there let me show
you that show now whisk until your
batter is silky smooth see how nice and
rich that is I'm popping the fridge to
chill next add that to the hot tray but
here's the secret behind a great
Yorkshire we have to get this just
smokin and it started to smoke then we
are off
and I'll have to be quick here have you
ever got that bubbling sizzling okay
another arise and then this is the most
important part that is vultures rise to
be the very best hey daddy's and my York
says rise to be the very best get money
on the phone get nanny on the phone he's
gonna see these I know it's Sunday lunch
so she's probably sleeping but let's get
money on the phone breaking news all
those years ago when you first showed me
how to make the most amazing huge
pudding I've just shown telly what you
showed me
and these Yorkers man they are gorgeous
if you could see these you can
understand why you gave birth to the
best chef in the world
[Laughter]
bye mum thank you for the amazing
recipes of course all the risk in but
hey lovely man just what's out what look
he always takes his Yorkshire pudding so
seriously yes I've lost my touch